To me,
the most evocative moment,
uh,
in decky hot as we reach the beautiful city of Barcelona is the appearance of
the sea.
The sea
suggests the infinite,
uh,
as we approached the end and also a death death dateless night to quote
Shakespeare Castille is landlocked.
Uh,
and so Spain
defining its limits,
uh,
as the novel ridges.
It's an undefined it's own,
uh,
limits,
Don Quixote on Sancocho.
Uh,
most probably have never seen the seat,
but Advantis,
uh,
certainly had as we know,
and he boasts of it in this,
uh,
last,
chapters of the Quixote.
There's all these details about life in the ships and of the Galley slaves and
all of that in which uses very detailed maritime,
uh,
terminology,
but sanctuary and,
and,
and not be haughty are unlikely to have ever seen the sea.
We are not,
uh,
told,
if they,
if they had,
but one I think should assume so
the novel,
uh,
which as a Java began with a cohort that will be an urban Java,
meaning that it will deal mostly with cities.
Settings will nearly always be cities.
Yet,
Barcelona is the only city that appears in the Quixote low.
Part two began,
uh,
with a visit to [inaudible] village
is donkey doing like any of us who went from Troy to Rome?
Obviously not.
Uh,
as I said earlier,
such heroic acts are no longer available to don Quixote.
Hemorrhoid can historically defining acts are not available to the whole thing
besides the torso is a mirror village in Spain and it endured no war like Troy.
And Barcelona is not the culmination of a journey and the harbinger of an empire
like the Roman,
which the need,
uh,
announcers and celebrates.
It is significant that in contrast to a history,
I'll repeat this,
a history of the novel,
which is mainly urban.
This is the only urban setting in Boca Hotel,
but it is urban with a vengeance.
Even with this partier,
I don't party,
which is very party,
very much something of the city.
And I'm thinking here of [inaudible],
which is the last volume in Marcel posts,
uh,
great,
novel.
Elijah sheriff's should you don't bear do,
which I hope you get read some day in which there are many parties at,
uh,
in that,
in that novel,
uh,
and dances and stuff.
Uh,
the first thing that don't get healthy and sang to endure,
uh,
in Barcelona is public shame as,
when the boys go to Rosie Nantais into throwing a don Quixote,
the city will mean public display of people.
It is also extremely significant that Don Quixote and Santiago arrive on the eve
of some Juan,
the night of the evil,
some one that is to say they arrived during carnival time or carnival like time.
Uh,
it is as he thought they had,
uh,
arrived at a costume party already costumed,
because,
uh,
the costume ball already costume because,
they are literary characters or re,
uh,
in fact,
by this date,
1615,
but by the time Cervantes is writing this 16,
13,
probably,
uh,
don't be haughty.
And central had already appeared in a,
in a carnival.
Two men disguised as Don Quixote on Santo appeared in a carnival in a town near
Lima,
Peru in 1609.
So look Quixote on Saint Joe.
We're already figures,
uh,
that,
costumes characters that people could dress up like in,
in the carnival.
And here they are entering into a carnival atmosphere.
The city of Barcelona will be a stage for various festivals and theater,
like representations.
The city is carnival,
it is theater,
it is acting out roles.
Uh,
it is the opposite of nature.
It is art.
Here we have little a literary Jonah's compressed on stage,
like the Byzantine Romance and the Novella Mariska that I explained about in the
last,
uh,
lecture.
Uh,
now the Byzantine Romance,
uh,
aspect or,
or representation I already,
uh,
mentioned,
it's also called a Greek romance.
This is the,
this meany Greek romance,
which winds up regardless as a [inaudible] gas Paris,
uh,
story,
Cervantes has compressed all of the elements of the Byzantine romancing the
abductions,
a sea voyage,
just a sea battles,
uh,
people,
in costume.
Uh,
and it is also,
uh,
please,
all of the,
uh,
captives tail,
with a good ending,
however,
promised for the,
uh,
to the Muslim,
father.
Uh,
I repeat what I said in the last lecture that at this time he said,
Ron,
this is working on his own Byzantine Romance,
the trials of penicillium and his Monda.
So it is,
uh,
it is,
not so pricing that he should include elements of it in this part of the
quarter.
They knew novelistic John Crow,
that Cervantes is creating is a compendium of narrative.
Jaras remember that the,
to me,
the most interesting,
uh,
aspect of this mini Byzantine romance is when,
Gaspard Gregorio is dressed as a woman,
so as to be less attractive to his Turkish captures is kind of a baroque kind of
transvestism.
Uh,
no transvestism sort of turned around.
now that story of [inaudible] Gregorio an ANA is not concluded.
There is no closure.
The reason may be that this is the only love story that has a social political
connection.
The whole business of the expulsion of the Maurice East and they're returning to
Spain,
uh,
against the law.
That is,
this is not just a story,
uh,
but part of ongoing history,
the novel that is the,
the novel Don Quixote,
like the character is coming closer to reality,
not to the demands of fiction or of madness,
perhaps closure other than death is only available in those realms.
There is closure is only available perhaps in fiction,
which it has this rounded completed forms,
whereas ongoing time cannot have a closure.
Perhaps closure is possible then only in fiction or within donkey.
This,
uh,
madness.
I am,
um,
I continue to worry about the ending of the novel gene pending ending of the
novel,
which must have worried around there's a lot as he moved
forward.
Now
it's Cervantes presenting a falsified Spain,
eh,
with this world to do citizens of Barcelona and government officials who are so
lenient with the Morris costs,
uh,
and the renegades,
or is it the Spain that he would like to see?
We will never know.
But on the whole,
there is leniency shown here,
even by the government officials who are breaking the law.
In doing so
now further,
uh,
activities in Barcelona take place at the house of Antonio Moreno,
Antonio Moreno character.
I'm sure that you have remarked upon.
And several social events take place at his house.
His house is now the,
the setting for,
for the action.
But we have left.
We have left and we'll return to the Duke and Duchess,
his house.
But now it's an Antonio Moreno's house.
At these events,
these social events take place.
Here we have depicted the pleasures of the bourgeois.
See,
this is not quite a Boudreaux.
it is higher than the Boudreaux.
See it is,
it announces the emergence of the Blue Jase as a class.
Now.
So the events here are not quite as elaborate or ornate as the ones at the,
uh,
the Duke and duchess is a palace mansion.
But then he said,
dance in which don't be haughty displace skills such as dancing that we did.
No,
we did not know that he possessed or imagine that he possessed.
They be speak of a past.
Uh,
that's Advantis chose not to fill out where it don't you hold the learn to
dance.
Where did he dance?
Just as we learned when the,
in the episode of the boat,
but he knows how to swim.
How did he ever learn how to swim?
We are not given any details about,
uh,
this past of don't be haughty.
We can,
we could imagine it.
Uh,
he acts here like an accomplished courtesan.
He is,
uh,
when he's at the Duke and Duchess,
his house,
the object of entertainment,
uh,
but not of cruel pracs.
I mean here,
this,
uh,
board a bourgeois half parties and suddenly a literary character emergents among
them.
It is a godsend to them.
Imagine you're having a party.
I'm James Bond.
Josep wow.
Everybody's excited.
And this is what happens at this party.
No,
the talking head Caper,
the talking head Kapor,
uh,
which is reminiscent of the master Peter Episode and his monkey remember the
monkey who could,
uh,
divine what is happening,
to people,
uh,
is,
making,
I mean the,
the,
the whole prank centers on making literal,
a rhetorical figure.
Remember I mentioned that [inaudible] was a rhetorical figure,
the name of the young woman in an earlier,
uh,
story.
Uh,
and now we have another one here.
Here we have broad support pay.
Yeah.
Okay.
In Spanish possible pay.
Yeah.
In English did the,
the definition of apple pay yeah.
Is a figure in rhetoric in which things are represented as persons or by which
things inanimate are spoken of as animated beings or by which an absent person
is introduced at speed as speaking or the CS person is represented as alive and
present the kind of personification.
Thus the,
the end of the definition,
uh,
you have possible pay.
Of course,
when you have a ventriloquist with his,
uh,
puppet that he makes the speak,
a projected his voice and speak.
So that is what [inaudible] is.
So seventh,
this here as he does in other occasions is hinting at the disconnection of
language from significant Haitian.
Okay.
It is a staging of pure voice without,
without a source.
Okay.
Well,
so he is playfully,
uh,
presenting the inner world of men as being made up of wood and 10,
because the,
uh,
the bus is made of wood
to made to look like stone or marble or whatever.
On the whole apparatus through which the student who is the assistant in this
case a speaks,
is made of,
uh,
of tin.
So,
uh,
here,
other than possible payer,
there is a hint.
The seventh,
this is joy.
Well,
you know,
the inside of of man is just like this piece of wood with a thin tube through
which the voice emerges.
Um,
so it,
it's again one of these,
uh,
episodes that has all kinds of philosophical her suggestions.
But the most suggestive episode in Barcelona is the visit to the printing shop.
Now this is the acme of self reflexivity.
It is us if jokingly Don Quixote,
we're visiting his true origin in the most material sense
Loki hotel,
a character who emerged from books.
He said the place where books are literally made,
it is a kind of reductio ad absurdum because literature cannot be reduced to the
material,
a status of paper,
ink and glue.
But you make a book with uh,
of course,
but to run this is delving into the very basic building blocks of his craft are
aware that these,
that is the,
the,
the apparatus,
the machinery to make the book and all of that,
our mere concrete manifestations of it that cannot be it real origin.
It's real source,
but he's playing with it.
Uh,
the episode,
this episode,
the most be seen in relation to the scrutiny of the books and to LTC Dora's
dream or vision about which I will speak later today.
They all deal with the question of the book,
the visit to the printing shop.
I repeat,
it's the last frontier of self reflexivity.
Here is a fictional character or observing the printing of a book about him.
But the book is an apocryphal one to add to the confusion.
It is [inaudible] book.
It is a visit to the origin of all reflections and representations.
The sign the boys hang on,
don't be haughty.
Also reduces him to do language is a label.
He is reduced to letters.
Okay,
so this is taking this to the very limits.
No spurious key.
Hot Day and we have a,
uh,
you have today,
a handout with the cover,
which I may have given you before just so that you have it as a souvenir.
You can also look at it and read it as best you can.
A notice of the ss are made,
uh,
like this,
go to the,
see Jess,
you can read it,
I'm sure.
And also the,
the woodcut of the night.
It's also very interesting.
I mean,
yeah,
that's uh,
uh,
superiors Jihad.
They came to the attention of Cervantes when he was about in chapter 36.
We set or 37.
Uh,
so the moment that he learned about our began adas book and probably on Reddit,
he changed those donkey hotel destination to Barcelona away from Santa Rosa.
I'm a,
yeah.
Nina's book allows you to run this,
to add yet another dimension to his play evolution.
Later he will borrow a character from the false Quixote and making swear that he
had never seen him and Saint Joe Don Quixote Hotel Center.
You will see that as we get to the very,
to the very end.
This is the,
this is a parody,
that legal document that he makes him sign.
Can you imagine a legal document is fictional characters making another one sign
saying,
and of course that he,
the one giving him the,
the document is the real one,
uh,
is a parody of those legal documents are the,
the origin of the constitution of,
of,
of the picaresque for instance.
Uh,
but that is a great deal more here.
There is a,
metta is a matter of fictional realm where characters from two different novels
can actually meet and talk to each other.
The play of Ellucian,
the blurring of the border between fantasy and fiction is emphasized by these
various layers of fiction involved when by the brilliant move by which Avantis
by not allowing them to go to Santa Rosa intends to correct history.
But of course it's a history that is a fiction.
There is no position from which to stand outside of the world of fiction in the
Kihatha because the fiction is manmade.
It is all that we can know in a way.
And I've mentioned this before,
this anticipates the philosophy of the great,
uh,
Italian philosopher Giambattista Vico
18th century.
The new science is the name of his wonderful book
because one of,
because,
uh,
main ideas was that mankind can only understand what mankind has made.
Uh,
therefore he begins his history of humanity after the flood,
when it is mankind that remakes the world,
not geneses.
And what I'm seeing here is that is that is this world of,
of,
of fiction is,
is manmade and it is all that we can understand.
Uh,
and uh,
so the modern self that emerges from this vision is a,
is a,
is a very light and fragile one like hamlets
or like the one proposed by Milan Kundera in the unbearable lightness of being
the normal that I,
uh,
that I suggest you read it.
It said,
modern self devoid of certainty,
certainly about himself or herself because the feeling that this miss on a beam,
this infinity receding sequence,
uh,
creates is that if anything envelops our world,
if anything contains our world,
may yet be another fiction.
This is the set of vantage bore.
Gestion bought his something referring to,
but Jorge Luis Borges,
this isn't said Advantium bore gestion predicament in which we finance ourselves
and from which you cannot escape in the guilty.
It is what we saw in Las Meninas when we visited Alaska studio on us.
And by watching we became a part of the fiction of the painting and the visit,
the visit to the printing shop is like the visit to the studio of Belasco Sis.
This is the shop where fiction is made.
The only way out of this predicament is by an act of will.
Like the ones that don't get hotter performs at the end when he very activity
spurns all of the seductions and all of the constellations that his calm rates
offer him.
I see his near death.
His is an act of faith and voluntary one,
not an intellectual one.
Moreover,
[inaudible],
he and his,
his,
his Quixote,
uh,
may also represent a misreading of Sarandos is Quixote by the society of his
time.
Uh,
[inaudible] presents a character that is essentially ridiculous and funny.
And I sang Joe who is a glutton and a drunk.
Uh,
so it is the,
the vision of,
uh,
of the US essentially a funny book.
Uh,
it,
miss reading that has been repeated in the,
in recent times by the so called hard school of critics have said around this in
England that I said that the only hard thing about it is the hardening of the
critical arteries.
Okay.
Peter Russell and company,
uh,
Anthony Close,
in a way,
uh,
said when this preempt all of them,
by doing what he does with [inaudible] got.
But the MS reading is interesting in itself.
If it is the miss reading,
it is interesting in itself.
Uh,
if I'm a [inaudible] book stands for that and we'd meet miss reading and I have
quotes from two critics,
one of whom you have heard before that will help clarify that potential was
reading and also situated historically.
One is,
uh,
Marty skull.
And I have looked all over to this corner,
this fellows first name and couldn't find that today.
Uh,
he wrote a book on our [inaudible],
uh,
Quixote.
He is,
uh,
a critic,
it,
uh,
who teaches at a university in California and he says he underscores,
reading,
uh,
by pointing out that,
that enable Yanina is book donkey Horta is actually chained and sent to jail,
not to Yale,
to jail.
Okay.
I cannot resist telling an anecdote here.
That is that my,
uh,
my mother who was a professor,
a very brilliant woman who,
uh,
who did very well in Greek and Latin,
but had little facility for modern languages,
including English.
And she would tell her friends in Florida to impress him.
My son Roberto is in jail.
And,
uh,
when the ladies did not react as she hoped,
she would say,
and he has been there a long time.
I had to,
I had to tell her to stop saying where I was teaching just to say that I was
teaching up north somewhere.
So in any case,
um,
uh,
in our DNA,
this book Doki hope that you sent to jail and a mighty scholar writes physical
imprisonment in the original text,
meaning in the Sorento says [inaudible] 1605,
with the exception of the open cage in the final chapters is displaced by a
series of images designed to explore the inescapable you had complex and often
10 years interrelationships between the self and the social world,
ropes,
strings,
nets.
You have a young Ada.
On the other hand,
the subject must be health forcibly in place so that it can be the recipient of
both the laws,
violence and the shame produced by exchanges with the community.
The subject here,
meaning gawky haughty,
he goes on.
The condemnation of Don Quixote by the subordinate classes merely underscores
the ideological homogeneity to which the Spanish elites with Ariana as spokesman
aspired.
So you can see,
I went your Neda,
uh,
medical is equating [inaudible],
imprisoning of the Quixote with the,
uh,
with the mainstream,
ideology of the Spanish of the Times.
He goes on our way.
Edda in prisons is uh,
his protagonist because he is mad,
meaning the protagonist,
not Oh,
you're Neda,
yet he's more pressing.
Ambition is to castigate the alternative forms of subjectivity which Cervantes
had explored in his novel the attempt to cultivate and individualized existence.
The attempt to cultivate an individualized existence.
Ron's head on not only into the traditional constraints of shame and revenge,
but finally into the twin powers of early Spanish absolutism without a year Neda
as their literary spokesman,
which work to suppress the attempt.
So Arianna is working to suppress these forms of subjectivity that are present
in the Quixote.
Finally,
the refusal to align himself with any of the hegemonic forces at work in his
society underscores a strong sense of wondering,
which has been noted by critics from Luca extra Fuko in the original chaotic by
moving along the margins of the dominant culture Cervantes system.
Kiata is not the romantic rebel,
which much of traditional criticism as one that him to be,
yet he nonetheless works to clear a space above which modern forms of
subjectivity would later appear unquote.
But if Carlos is not aware that the individual alternative forms of subjectivity
that he talks about our mood,
you are in origin and destination,
if we are going to see them from the marketing point of view,
that he,
I presume,
uh,
is,
is looking at them from moreover,
he works,
I think with a utopian vision of the liberated self.
That's the one this would have never been naive enough to accept.
But what he says is very suggestive about the source of,
uh,
concept of the,
of the character that he has taken from Cervantes.
Manuel do run who you have encountered many times,
writes Gilman,
Steven Gilman,
whom you have also met many times professor at Harvard for many years and he
wrote the best,
uh,
works on,
on,
on our agenda.
Gilman has demonstrated the coincidence between Avaya Neda's attitude and that
of post council of Trent moral.
It's morals which were ascetic and Orthodox are young.
You know,
now what the Council of Trent is because you've read it in Elliot.
No,
this is a retrenchment of a Catholic orthodoxy in the sprain of the time.
Are Your Neda would then be the representative of all of the people's voice.
But this does not explain why are your Neda shows himself to be so favorable to
the Maurice course,
which he does.
He's Aragon is origin.
The irregular were against the explosion,
which is probable is not sufficient proof.
In any case,
if one accepts that are a [inaudible] book is a kind of negative collective
response by Spain Society of the Times too,
the freedom and inner independence with which Cervantes are endowed his
characters.
We will then understand why serve and this did not have immediate and direct
successors and the reason why the modern novel invented in Spain by Advantis
would have to wait until the middle of the 19th century to be able to return to
its birthplace official Spain.
Those on Honduran in contrast to the nearly underground Spain found in a path
that goes from Rojas and the mystics to serve.
Aunties did not believe in individual independence and freedoms.
What he means.
Uh,
but Durham means here is that there is an official Spain here,
Orthodox and becoming increasingly Orthodox in the 16th century.
But there is an underground Spain that goes from Rojas,
meaning Fernando,
the Rojas,
the author of cellists,
Tina,
uh,
through the mystics,
Saint John of the cross and so forth who were seen with great suspicion by the
inquisition,
uh,
to serve on this.
And the,
this is a counter,
uh,
official,
Spain,
but data with Geneva represents Orthodox,
uh,
Spain here above this which suppresses it.
And that's why he gives us that view of the chaotic,
I hope this is,
uh,
this is,
this is clear.
Okay.
Cervantes is relatively mild response.
That's where I would like to put all the,
the hard school of critics there with that,
the Orthodox Spain that represses,
you know,
uh,
now Cervantes is relatively mild response to our [inaudible] is in line with his
irony.
There is a great deal of humor in what,
on what he does [inaudible] and we'll see it immediately when we get to LTC,
Dora's vision.
And I run,
just like I said,
if I run this can never be so sure of himself as to be very island in
controversy and in debate.
Okay.
How can they be so sure of himself?
One of servant this is most admired traits is this restraint and self mockery.
And it shows in his answered [inaudible] if you remember the 1605 prologue,
you remember this self mocked instead of one person who doesn't know how to,
what to do about writing the prologue and so forth and so on.
And all of this,
uh,
Horyo games by which he distanced himself from his creation and all of that.
Someone with that position,
uh,
good.
Only due to our agenda,
what he did according to Gillman,
you sort of threw a net of irony over a million data to capture him.
Okay?
He did say a few nasty things in the prologue,
the 1615,
he hold them.
But uh,
of course Allie,
Anita had said terrible things about,
uh,
[inaudible] blocked him even because TV is in your hand on everything.
It was,
no,
no.
Now we come to this what I think is the culminating event in Barcelona,
which is donkey holders defeat at the hands.
Well,
the night of the white moon.
Uh,
the night of the white moon is the latest reincarnation of Samsung Carrasco whom
we learn has been pursuing his neighbors since his failure as the night of the
mirrors.
He's now in cahoots with the Duke and Duchess who tell him where Don Quixote has
gone because Samsung looked for him in Santa Rosa and did not find him there.
Of course,
the rules are carefully agreed upon as with the earlier,
uh,
encounter and Don Quixote is fairly defeated within those rules.
He speaks as if dead from within his armor as you lay on the ground.
He said,
uh,
that the narrator says Don Quixote,
Bruce Johnstone without lifting up his visor as if he was speaking from within a
tomb in a feeble and low boys said and so forth.
Boredom,
Quixote.
After you've Doki hot,
they had been killed.
This would have been a possible ending,
but even in defeat,
but he's been defeated.
The,
this could have ended the novel too.
Why doesn't it?
Well it doesn't because he has not Jared a jet given up his persona as knight
errant,
uh,
has the process of his coming to himself.
It's not just finished.
And as I told you,
that is the,
the,
he most of his most important task,
the task that is comparable to the hell Roy one that,
uh,
that nes accomplishes in,
in virtual
the profound suggestion of donkey halters defeat at the hands of the night of
the white moon is that given that this night,
like the night of the mirrors,
a reflection of donkey Horta himself,
it may be that the doe is being defeated by some projection of his own inner
world.
Even part one.
Don't you hold,
this body is imprisoned in the cage.
Ah,
here it is as if his spirit where the one,
uh,
being defeated,
but it is again,
as you don't get hot,
they were conquered by his own reflection,
by a projection of something within,
within his own self.
This is what is profound about this scene.
It is easy to establish.
Of course,
at the night of the [inaudible],
the white moon not only is an image of Don Quixote,
remember the Luna Luna,
uh,
meant the reflecting part of a mirror,
La Luna,
the less pickle,
but also that lunatic refers to donkey hope.
This madness,
the moon,
of course,
it's a celestial body of reflected light.
So that song is reflecting donkey Hotez light in a way or don't the tortoise,
the projection of Don Quixote's spirit.
I am intrigued by the,
the name of this night,
which seems to be redundant.
I mean,
the moon is always white,
white moon.
The debris white moon seems to cancel,
cancel itself out to cancel itself out in,
in,
in its repeated white ness like the springs to mind,
the white peril upon the white forehead at the end of Dante's Paradiso,
white Parallon Beatrice's forehead loose cannot be seen because it's wide open.
White Don Quixote is fight.
It's fighting as it were,
against his own nothingness that,
uh,
that,
light being that I mentioned before when alluding to hamlet and two Kundera,
uh,
is nothingness,
which is this white upon white,
the disappears unto itself because white can also mean absence and in,
in,
and in that sense,
the night of the white moon can also be an image of death.
Is there any significance to the significance of the fact that no Quixote is
defeated by the sea
on the shore in an open space that is nevertheless from tear a border between
land and water?
Remember what I said at the very beginning about the sea evoking,
for me at least an image of death.
Uh,
it is,
uh,
an image of the infinite and of death there.
It seems to be a correspondence to me anywhere.
But anyway,
anyway,
between the Hawaii of the,
of,
of the night and the sea,
so this is this dramatic,
uh,
the fetal lucky hotel where he has to accept the conditions set out before the
fight.
And so they begin to trudge back to her village.
And,
uh,
we have this marvelous pastoral interlude.
Uh,
don't get hotter.
Imagines a life as a shepherd drawn from the pastoral romances.
A set run.
This in a way is adding to,
this is what I've called a smorgasbord of narrative modes,
the pastoral,
but only as a project by Don Quixote.
This will be a novel,
another novel parallel to the Quixote in which the pastoral romances,
uh,
would play the role of the chief Valerie quants.
Remember that we have had a meanie Byzantine Romance and many Mareeska,
uh,
novel.
And if you,
uh,
if you remember,
on pages nine oh four,
nine oh five,
eh,
he says,
don't go there.
This is the metal of where like it on the gay where we light it on.
The gay shepherded says,
and Garant shepherd shepherds who intended to revive it and imitate the pastoral
Arcadia.
They thought us new as ingenious in imitation of which if you approve,
if you approve it,
I could wish all Sanctu we might turn.
Shepherds are this from the time I must have lived retired,
meaning according to what he has agreed.
Uh,
uh,
I will buy sheep and all of the materials necessary for the pastoral employment
and I calling myself the shepherd exotic skip studies.
And you're the shepherd Pan Theano.
We will range the mountains,
the woods and metals singing here and complaining.
They're drinking the liquid crystal of the fountains of the Limpid Brooks or of
the mighty rivers,
the oaks and so forth.
This is the description of this Arcadia,
uh,
the pastoral.
It is a hilarious metta novel that he imagines here in which the would be
shepherds don Quixote on sanctuary.
The priest and barber and Samsung would take pastoral names that we have seen
derived from their own,
uh,
and give names to the ladies.
Remember Angelo says he's going to call his wife Terry Sauna with the
argumentative because apparently she is.
Jesus is fat McKim.
Uh,
this is the world of [inaudible] air clogs brought to Don Quixote's mind as he
mentioned it by the episode of the young women who are preparing to,
to stage one of the backlogs,
which has been anticipated by all the references to the poet in this part too.
And they will be more
resourceful also is circling back to sort of Lantus.
His first book law gala,
Remember,
uh,
which he always said he would write a,
which he always said he would write a second part in this new normal that would
be a world of love without violence and ideal neoplatonic universe.
The same clash appears in the Kihatha between a fallen present and an ideal pass
that cannot be revived in his projected novel.
Not to mention that all the potential characters are too old.
Do we?
Pastoral lovers and one is a priest who got beaten all over at all.
So,
uh,
it is a kind of a grotesque,
achieve,
uh,
pastor pastoral romance,
in,
in the making as the hotel is in some ways also a grotesque achieve Alaric
romance.
This is followed by an episode,
the episode where they run over by,
by a herd of pigs,
uh,
that,
the critics have found that that's Advantis tinker around or where to place this
episode.
Uh,
um,
but the important thing is that there seems to be no end to the humiliations and
Don Quixote is,
is enduring towards the end of the book because,
uh,
remember,
that there is nothing worse than a pig or a or a or a swine herd,
which is the word I was looking for the other day and could not find when
alluding to that,
uh,
the episode where sanctuary has to pass judgment on the man who allegedly raped
a woman and so forth.
And man was a swine herd.
And so we,
they are heroes.
I returned forcing lead to the Duke and Duchess as house.
These are not satisfied with all the pranks that they have made them Quixote on
sanctuary,
endure and prepare yet another elaborate one for them when they are,
when they hear of the night's defeat and returned to their village,
said,
Advantis inserts.
Here is Tate meant by sit Hamot to underline the questionable state of mind of
this frivolous aristrocrats he says,
quote,
page nine,
nine nine nine one nine.
And Sit Ahmed says,
besides that to his thinking,
the mockers,
whereas mine is the marked and the Duke and Duchess,
where with within two fingers breadth of appearing to be mad themselves since
they took so much pains to make it just of the two fools.
So this is a world where there has been a contamination of,
of,
of madness,
uh,
from character to character.
This kit with the dental teach you,
Nora is full of literary resonances.
The staging is elaborate with bleachers for the audience and elevated place for
the Duke and Duchess and blazing lights to turn night into day.
Uh,
this is such as the artifice that night is turned in today with all these
lights,
centuries costume in a shroud of flames on,
on,
on an abundant with devils on it,
uh,
which seemed to be done.
Teske Ellucian and the lines we cited,
Alicia,
one of the updates recited during the year.
This kid are directly taken from Garcia lassos portrait.
The farce.
It's a representation of the death of the beloved in the courtly love tradition
and in renaissance poetry.
The famous deaths are those of Beatrice Dante,
Laura Patriarch and Isabell,
Freddy Garcia Lasso.
He says three ladies there,
death mark,
the port g of these major ports,
dividing their work into a before and an after,
before the death of Laura after the devil Laura before the death of each,
I'm afraid after that and so forth.
Uh,
so this is very significant moment in the,
in the,
in the history of,
of,
of Western portrait that has to be on stage here.
This is the representation of arrows and [inaudible] of love and death,
but in a baroque farce involving the protagonist and with a whole household,
it seems in attendance,
this is a prank as elaborate as a pageant in the forest,
it is a repetition of it.
A central's fall in the pit was a repetition of the cave of Montesinos episode.
Sanchez body is again the object or better the vehicle for expiation and the
Duenas are his executioners.
That is they're going to slap him around and pinch him and stick pins in his
butt and so forth.
And this is what will allow until she got up to be revived.
Why,
why?
Again,
it seems that central has been cast in the role of the fool
who must suffer all the physical shenanigans,
meaning the full drawn from the carnival tradition.
Uh,
this is a reading of his figure that is parallel to the one of Neda made by
turning him to a farcical,
glutton and drunk,
meaning the reading that these,
uh,
Duke and Duchess and there are many have done essential,
because remember they have read,
part one is parallel to the one that [inaudible] made.
This is why he is made to endure this,
uh,
this,
humiliations don't be haughty.
The flames or in his dress and the lighting of the courtyard seemed to be an
illusion to dido who burned herself to death when abandoned by Eunice don't.
The hottest return and impending departure are luck.
An ansys and LTC door,
again is playing the role of Dido,
her anger,
and her insults,
which are very colorful and actually accurately described Don Quixote,
who's very ugly.
It looks like a candle that she says and all of these things.
But all of these,
all of these,
uh,
truths play into the fixture because they sound that you stay in them in spite
because he's leaving her.
So even this,
these truths are absorbed into,
into,
into the fiction.
The whole episode is thick with literary references and it's staging,
uh,
it is a staging of great literature,
and reducing it to play.
Now remember,
most were doing this or the Dutcher's and the Duke who are,
there's a prankster aristrocrats.
Uh,
now the most remarkable passage in the whole sequence sequence of episodes
involving RTC Dora is her infernal vision is one of my favorite passages in the
whole book.
St George,
who remember,
is curious to learn.
What are these Laura saw when she was dead?
Uh,
what the afterworld was like.
He wants to know,
particularly hell.
He wants to know what hell is like.
Now notice that LTC notice infernal voyage is like donkey hope descend to the
cave of Montesinos and Sanchez fall into the pit LTC donors reply,
which she must have made up on the spot.
Like Dorothea the story of Princess Mikami.
Part one is a truly brilliant boast of imaginative skill on her part and of
course on Cervantes.
This
patient nine 20 in truth,
cope antics.
You Dora,
I could not quite die
since I went not to hell for her.
I once set foot in it.
I could not have got out again though I had never so great desire.
Remember that those who enter hell at the entrance of hell in Nundah Telesis
lose all hope you cannot ever get out of here.
The truth is,
I came to the gate,
were about a dozen devils were playing a tennis below ties in Spanish.
They say tennis.
Tennis was not in very inviting,
invented into the 18th century.
So the Jarvis is indulging in a little anachronism here,
but it's close enough
in their wast coast and drawers.
There should cars ornamented with Flanders lays and ruffles of the same with
four inches of their risks.
Bear to make your hand seem longer in which they have rackets of failure.
But what I wondered most odd was that instead of tennis balls,
they made use of books seemingly stuffed with wind and flux and think marvelous,
a new look.
This,
uh,
did some niche,
but these are the not so much wonder at us to see that we're as it is natural
for winning.
There's to rejoice and losers to be sorry among the games there's of that place
all grumbled,
all were upon the fret and all curse one another.
That is not at all strange answers.
Sanctuary for devils play or not play,
win or not win can never be contented.
Centuries knowledgeable about what happens in health.
Of course he knows the oral tradition about what is in health and,
and how it is true growth.
LTC Laura.
But there is another thing I wondered at,
I mean I wonder,
I had it then she has to correct herself because she's speaking in the
precedence is,
oh no,
no.
Here's what I,
and she's making it up such as again,
I say,
I remember that,
that uh,
dawn of day it makes a mistake,
uh,
also on,
has to be corrected when she's making it up,
which was that the first pass the ball was demolished and could not serve a
second time.
And so they whipped them away and a new and old that it was marvelous to behold
unto one of them flaming new and new and neatly bound.
They give such a smart stroke that they made it its guts fly out and scattered
his leaves all about.
And one devil said to another,
see what that book is on the other devil.
Answer it.
If the second part of the history of donkey hotel,
Amanda not composed by seed Hamlet,
it's first author but by an error agonies who calls himself a native of tore the
seizures.
You have that on a cover of a,
you need us a way where that growth,
you're the devil and down with it to the bottom of the infernal abyss that my
eyes may never see it more.
He said,
it's so bad.
I said the other so bad replied the first that had I my cell phone,
then take it to make it worse.
It had been passed my skill.
They went on with replay tossing all their books up and down and so forth.
There is a lot of Dante in this episode,
but the story of devil's playing a form of tennis Bellota uh,
with the souls are the heads of the dead is a traditional story gruesome,
but,
uh,
Cervantes embroidered,
embroidered upon it by making them use books instead of a headset or soles for
boss.
The attack on our way Janita is very funny.
Uh,
but the commentary on books goes beyond the Apocrypha for uh,
[inaudible].
Uh,
this episode reflects a change in the appraisal and the appraisal of books.
By the beginning of the 17th century in the West,
their value has diminished.
It seems to follow an elementary economic law.
With the advent of the printing press,
the number of books increased dramatically.
Then the value of each decreased.
I mean,
this is basic economics,
but it is more complicated than that
philosophy move toward knowledge as the result of the experience,
not as something acquired from authoritative sources who's works were in books
in Spain,
neo scholasticism about which you have read in Elliot,
which was a revival of the medieval philosophy of the church fathers and which
relied on syllogism and the opinion of authoritative sources had become the
ideology of the state.
Neo scholasticism doctoring,
whatever you want to call it,
and religious template.
It was the ideology of the Spanish crown,
logical argumentation and authorities supplied the foundations of knowledge.
Uh,
the,
we have seen something of that and I mentioned it in the satire of doctors in
the person of doctor,
uh,
or [inaudible] who says to Sandra,
you cannot,
you cannot deny that the,
the knowledge of medicine at the time was based in play on books,
not an experience.
So the situation in the rest of Europe was known as extreme,
but philosophical thought nonetheless rejected bookish learning in favor of
experience and individual thought.
The greatest exponent of these was Dick Carr,
whom I have mentioned several times in the course of the semester.
I had a pre cursor review racial door in a milder or lighter kind of
philosophical speculation was Montana.
Yeah,
I'm funny.
Grafton,
Grafton professor at Princeton
and Anthony Grafton,
uh,
opens the introduction of his magnificent book,
New World's ancient texts,
the power of tradition and the shock of discovery,
uh,
with these words quote between 15,
50 and 1650 western thinkers,
theories to believe that they could find all important truths in ancient books
on quote graft and goes on to quote Jesuit Jose Acosta.
Okay.
Who published a,
a very important book,
a very comprehensive book about the history of the new world goal is Toryonn.
Okay.
E moral what art means.
Culture,
not rallies,
uh,
physical,
of the nature and moral beans.
Uh,
culture.
they lost India's
book is from the 1590s,
1592 or something like that.
I can't remember what he says.
He quotes a Acosta who says the following
quote,
having read what poets and philosophers,
right,
of the torrid zone.
I persuaded myself that when I came to the equator,
you send a ship on his way to the new world.
I would not be able to endure the heat,
put it turned out otherwise.
For when I passed the equator,
I felt so cold that I was forced to go into the sun to warm myself.
What could I do?
What laugh at Aristotle's meteorology says across the top,
this is mocked,
by the way,
uh,
in chapter 29 of part two,
and the episode of the enchanted boat,
uh,
beaning.
Dot.
The actual experience of travel demolishes traditional knowledge,
traditional knowledge being whether Saint Joe's or lice who die when they cross
a certain line and so forth.
Remember,
all of that is mobile.
This is what he's behind it.
I run weekly.
Then the proliferation of books being,
uh,
at the other time when the authority of the book was most severely tested and
ultimately the value there is the proliferation of,
of,
of books takes place at the time when the authority of the book was most
severely tested and ultimately devalued.
Okay.
The ability to read many books did not bring one closer to wisdom,
uh,
both to an inordinate,
perhaps in feed it a large amount of the library and perhaps to Don Quixote's is
Matt.
Yes.
I believe that this is what is implicit in this marvelous passage overall DC
Dora's infernal visitation
as customer.
He said one,
this deals with very complicated issues in such an unaffected,
spontaneous,
and amazed and amusing way that it seems almost like a,
like a miracle.
Oh,
this is what is behind this,
uh,
episode about books being,
walked with parenting flaming rackets.
We will be dealing,
uh,
chiefly with the end of the Quixote in the last two lectures.